what
to you is iran's best idea
one that uh you find impactful
insightful useful for us in modern
society that you think about
that your life has meaning
and productive work is your highest
value
and that you shouldn't apologize and
this is something i despise
you shouldn't apologize for saying i
want to be happy
and i'm going to work toward that and
that
is a few others that you owe nobody else
some random stranger
a second of your time you see this a lot
on twitter
and social media people like demanding a
debate or demanding you act a certain
way
and engage with them you don't know them
anything um
so i think those are some of her uh uh
best ideas
and she teaches you how to think iran
does not have all the answers but she
has all the questions
do you think uh what do you think about
the whole selfishness thing i mean do
you see
do you are you triggered by the word
selfishness so it's really unfortunate
what she does
because you were just talking earlier
about mold bug being carelessly
she this is indefensible in my opinion
so she talks about the virtue of
selfishness
and she claims that when people talk
about selfishness they
they mean concern primarily with the
self they don't
when people talk about selfishness they
mean in a sociopathic way
concerned exclusively with oneself right
they mean like oh
if someone is dying on the street i'm
not gonna you know
even waste a second saving them because
i'm selfish
so she sets up this complete caricature
of the term
what she when she's attacking
selflessness in her best
sense is when there are people who have
no
sense of self they have no values of
their own
they have no goals of their own
everything that's in their mind is
gotten second hand from the culture at
large
and there's nothing unique or special
from their perspective
worth fighting for so when she attacks
um
which she advocates for the self she
basically means self-development
self-improvement and achievement so i
think that word choice
is really um it false
and needlessly off-putting yeah
controversial perhaps for the purpose of
being controversial
i don't know but it's just it's not
accurate that's not what people mean by
selfishness
yeah i would say it's one of the one of
the reasons probably her philosophy is
uh not as much adopted or thought about
it's like it's funny like the use of
words mean something
exactly as you said that's my criticism
mentions mob which could be incorrect
criticism by the way
so i'm not exactly sure
you